steve jobs and apple have quite a cult
whether lining up for days outside apple
stores to get the new iphone first
or defending every questionable move
from apple
whether that's the removal of the
headphone jack or the power brick
apple fanboys support anything and
everything that comes out of apple
and this was really quite a wonder at
the time
but today the quote of elon musk is far
larger than any cult steve jobs was able
to accumulate
so how is elon musk able to grow such a
positive and supportive cult
[Music]
before we get started here i wanted to
make it clear that
i'm not trying to criticize anyone for
admiring or looking up to elon musk
personally i look up to him as well and
think he's a great role model aside from
this
i think most of us here would agree that
elon musk is one of the most important
people in the world
if not the most important with that
being said
what i would like to discuss here is
what leads tens of millions of people to
idolize them to an extent
where they block out all criticism of
the guy and
it's not just me who's suggesting this
but elon musk himself
a few years ago when elon musk was asked
what is the biggest challenge of his
life
here's what he said one of the biggest
challenges i think
is making sure you have a corrective
feedback loop
and then maintaining that corrective
feedback loop over time
even when people want to tell you
exactly what you want to hear
that's very difficult yes so clearly
even elon musk himself understands and
acknowledges
that his fan base is often extremely
uncritical of him
so much so that staying neutral is one
of his biggest challenges
and let's keep in mind that this is
coming from a guy who has achieved some
of the hardest technical feats
in history but what makes people feel so
strongly
about elon musk well starting off
many fans believe that elon musk is the
savior of humanity
there is definitely at least some
substance disbelief
as elon musk is doing a lot of great
things from fighting climate change
on multiple fronts to making our species
multi-planetary
and to many people these are the most
noble and
important battles to fight as they
concern all of us
no one is going to argue that fighting
poverty or various deadly diseases
is not significant but at the same time
these issues are more concerned with
improving the overall quality of human
life
as sad as it is kids in africa and third
world countries dying from poverty
and disease doesn't actually affect the
chances of human survival
as a whole on the contrary many of
elon's fans believe that ignoring
climate change
and staying confined to one planet is a
long-term death wish for entire species
though i do believe that elon musk is
significantly helping us tackle these
issues
i'm not exactly convinced that humans as
a whole would go extinct without
contributions
of elon musk this is because i believe
that the overall human community
will not let such disasters actually
take place long term
humans have overcome many existential
threats in the past
such as the ice age which lasted a
millennium
so though i don't believe elon musk is
the sole savior of humanity
i think there's no problem with strongly
supporting a guy who has made great
strides
in many important fields moving on elon
musk comes off as one of the most real
billionaires out there
we rarely see any emotions coming out of
the wealthiest people around
with jeff bezos the only emotion we see
out of him
is his quote-unquote maniacal laughing
with the mark zuckerberg
you know the story and with bernard
arnold
well most people don't even know he's at
the top of the billionaires list
with elon musk on the other hand one of
the most famous clips of him
is him tearing up and being able to see
the emotional side of someone
no doubt makes it easier for people to
sympathize with them
which also leads to greater admiration
when they succeed against all odds
aside from this one of the key
proponents to his thriving fan base
is of course his constant engagement
with them through social media
some people hate elon's tweeting while
others love it
but i think everyone finds it at least
entertaining to some degree
and given that elon tweets several times
every single day
he is able to connect with his fan base
on a regular basis
ensuring that his fan base remains
strong anyways
next up one of the largest reasons that
many people have a crush on elon musk
is because of the nature of his projects
now
i'm not talking about the difficulty or
importance of elon's work
but rather the nature of elon's work
elon's projects are often compared to a
kid
in a candy shop just pouncing at every
idea that seems intriguing
every idea he's working on is something
many of us have dreamt about
as a kid whether launching rockets into
space
or visiting mars or inventing a car that
can drive
itself and what about neurolink i bet
many of us have dreamt about becoming as
smart as supercomputers
one day elon's ideas aren't the most
unique
or original as such visions are common
amongst many people
especially when they were younger
however the average person matures
and usually ends up working a 9 to 5 job
and
never looks back at the vision they had
when they were younger
with elon musk however not only did he
embark on these endeavors
but he has been successful with many of
them
as a result through elon musk i believe
many of his fans were able to fulfill
their own dreams from when they were
younger
though it's actually not them achieving
their dreams they're excited to support
someone who is
actually working on making their dreams
a reality
with that being said i think a lot of
the enthusiasm
for elon musk comes from how the
projects capture the kid
within all of us in the realm of
succeeding in ludicrous innovations
something that's unique to elon musk is
that his rate of innovation
never slows down rather it actually
speeds up
this is in stark contrast to many of the
other top innovators in the world
for instance with apple we saw rapid
innovation
from the original iphone to the iphone
6. every year
there would be something significant
that people would want to upgrade for
after the iphone 6 however we saw a bit
of a stall
until the iphone x which came out three
years later
and since then we haven't seen very much
innovation
at all out of apple this can of course
be partially attributed to the fact that
smartphones have evolved to basically
their final form however with the chosen
fields of elon musk
there is really no final form due to the
massive scope
of his fields with space for instance we
have to first reach mars
but though reaching mars is extremely
difficult
actually reaching mars is just the
beginning after that
there's the extremely difficult goal of
colonizing and terraforming mars
if we succeed with this on one planet
why not extend it to other
more difficult planets as well like
venus or the gas giants
if we succeed within our solar system
then the next obvious step
would be stepping outside the solar
system and then our galaxy and so on and
so forth
when it comes to the exploration and
colonization of our universe
the possibilities are truly endless
which allows elon musk to never slow
down the rate of innovation
as is common with most other innovative
companies and
this rapid speed of innovation keeps the
fans of elon musk
constantly on the edge of the receipt
wondering when the next milestone will
be
and finally the last major reason elon
musk has been able to build up such an
extensive community
is that he doesn't do anything for the
money
rather the vast fortune he has been able
to accumulate
is simply a byproduct this is very
evident in the fact that he started
spacex
and even got involved with tesla in the
first place
elon musk received 180 million from the
sale of paypal to ebay
and he could have called it a day right
then
most people would be more than satisfied
with that amount
and wouldn't even care to grow it but
even if elon wanted to grow it further
there were many easier options available
to him he could have simply thrown the
180 million into the s p 500
and called it a day given the 464
return the s p 500 has produced with the
dividends we invested over the past 18
years
elon musk could have upwards of 1
billion today just by betting on the s p
if he wanted to spice it up a bit he
could have just thrown 10 million
dollars
at each of the rapidly growing tech
companies in 2002
like amazon apple microsoft and google
which were quite reasonably priced after
dot com crash
considering that apple has grown over
400 x since 2002 and
similar returns or better are the cases
with other top tech companies as well
elon could have easily grown his 180
million dollars to tens of billions
today
by doing absolutely nothing himself but
he didn't do this instead he decided to
risk it all with an ev
and space company even today he publicly
releases
many of the designs and innovations of
tesla and spacex for free
to help the other ev and space companies
push the entire field forward
and evidently this causes many of elon's
fans to view his work
as noble and wholesome unlike the work
of some other billionaires
at the end of the day elon musk works on
problems that affect all
of humanity he's very relatable he
fulfills our own childhood dreams
and he doesn't do any of it for the
money and
this set of characteristics has
organically grown a massive cult-like
following for elon
today and though i think many of the
people
in this group should be more critical of
elon musk where it's warranted
considering everything we've discussed
so far it's no wonder why elon's fan
base is so strong
today do you guys consider yourself a
member of this cult
comment that down below also drop a like
if you're convinced elon is critical to
our future
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one